la mairie de monnaie mise sur le
dispositif argent de poche comme
plusieurs communes du Val de Loire elle
recrute des jeunes entre 16 et 18 ans
pendant leurs vacances scolaires
l'objectif effectué des petits travaux
pour la municipalité contre rémunération
les adolescents travaillent au maximum
17h30 par semaine et sont payés au SMIC
jeune clémence dausques a rencontré
trois d'entre eux
tente de se remettre dans le bain en
avril dernier le lycée en participait au
dispositif argent de poche de sa commune
une manière de gagner un peu d'argent
entre ces 16 et 18 ans l'aventure il a
tenté ici au centre de loisirs situé à
l'école de monnaie je crois que j'ai
gagné environ 300 je sais plus peut-être
et ça va me servir pour me payer mon
code plus tard mineur les volontaires ne
travaillent pas plus de 17h30 par
semaine pour 97,5 euros les horaires
dépendent de leur petit boulot tous dans
les corps de la collectivité pas en
stage d'observation mais en immersion
les jeunes gagnent en autonomie sans
avoir toutes les responsabilités d'un
salarié j'ai préféré prendre l'animation
parce que
j'ai jamais été très à l'aise avec les
enfants donc ça m'a permis d'être un peu
plus à l'aise en fait tout simplement de
d'acquérir des connaissances
et ça m'a même ouvert les portes pour le
BAFA Arthur et Manon ont été scolarisés
dans l'établissement lorsqu'ils étaient
petits ce retour en terrain connu permet
d'aborder plus sereinement les premiers
pas dans la vie professionnelle j'y ai
passé toute mon enfance le matin et la
soirée aussi c'est exactement pareil
tous les posters qu'on mettait avant les
tables etc tout pareil la formule
fonctionne depuis deux ans près d'une
vingtaine de jeunes mondéniens en défilé
un simple poste Facebook qui est le
bouche à oreille on fait l'affaire le
dispositif s'est mis en place il y a
deux ans donc nous avons commencé il y a
plus de 25 enfants donc qui ont déjà
participé certaines communes nous
appellent pour nous demander un petit
peu comment ça se passe le dispositif
est donc proposé à Rochecorbon et
monnaie en Indre-et-Loire et Salbris
dans le Loir-et-Cher les inscriptions se
font en se rapprochant des mairies